[Música]
[Aplausos]
si te portas mal
le voy a llamar al médico para que te
inyecte
todos hemos escuchado esta frase alguna
vez en nuestra vida tal vez hasta
víctimas de la misma frase incluso el
médico que es famoso por llevar la bata
a todos lados desde estudiante va
pasando por ahí en el hospital y la mamá
va pórtate bien no te lleva el doctor
de manera indirecta
sin querer nos alimentan estas madres
esas personas de un cierto temor
acercarnos a alguien que en un momento
determinante de nuestras vidas cuando
más vulnerables estamos
cuando más necesitamos de ayuda nos pone
una barrera para buscarla
la jatropha obvia es el término que
utilizamos para el temor injustificado
inminente e irracional de acudir al
médico en busca de ayuda por temor
el miedo en la salud es de lo que
hablaremos el día de hoy
pero el miedo es un instinto primitivo
un instinto que nos ha mantenido a salvo
y ha permitido que evolucionamos como
humanos y como sociedad el miedo
nos prepara ante cualquier evento
adverso
cuando tenemos miedo nuestro corazón
empieza a latir más fuerte más rápido
los pulmones lanzan más oxígeno a
nuestra sangre los vasos se cierran en
honor en donde no se ocupan y se abren
los músculos preparados para atacar o
para huir
cuando yo era muy pequeño y una de las
primeras anécdotas en la salud que yo
tengo es que la chica que nos asistía en
casa tenía crisis convulsivas mi hermana
y yo de siete y ocho años apenas tomamos
decisiones sin saber mi hermano salía
corriendo con mi abuelita que vivía al
lado a pedirle auxilio que ella tampoco
sabía qué hacer y salía con la vecina
después venían ambas que no sabían qué
hacer y le echaban aire
yo me quedaba ahí
sin saber mucho que hacer buscando que
no se golpeara buscando que no sirviera
y que se hiciera más daño tal vez una de
esas anécdotas es lo que me hace ser
médico y estar aquí con ustedes
si quieren saber lo que es el miedo
el miedo se acompaña de sentimientos de
temor de angustia aprensión e impotencia
imagínense todos ustedes que sus
celulares que lo tienen ahí un lado está
sin clave su pareja al lado de ustedes y
casualmente voltea a verlo empieza el
corazón a latir más fuerte
una conversación whatsapp
y el corazón late más fuerte
quién es
ella y el corazón está
así
si ya sintieron esto
ya saben lo que es el miedo
y el miedo yo lo vivo todos los días en
mi consultorio el miedo yo lo vivo
porque mis pacientes que están frente a
mí del otro lado del escritorio tienen
este corazón agitándose todos los días
porque tienen temor a que les des una
mala noticia
este temor los lleva a veces a tomar
decisiones equivocadas ya buscar algo
que le llamamos las puertas falsas estas
fotos se las pongo con mucho orgullo
pero al mismo tiempo muy honrado de
haber participado en una actividad de
hace muchos años y este señor que está
aquí hincado se llama juan y juan era mi
traductor en san cristóbal de las casas
y era que me apoyaba para poder dar
consulta en las comunidades indígenas
junto a juan capacitamos a muchos otros
médicos tradicionales como él para poder
reconocer los signos de alerta y poder
llevar estos pacientes a buscar la ayuda
en el lugar correcto
no fue fácil tuvimos muchas cosas en
alguna ocasión ya me van a dejar
amarrado un póster voy a decirle a un
médico tradicional que no debería de
usar antibióticos de manera
indiscriminada tiempo después los
antibióticos se previeron y sólo se
venden con receta en aquel entonces era
muy difícil
es muy fácil buscar una puerta falsa y
caer en el juego
cuando tú tienes necesidad de una
solución pero sabes que la solución te
puede poner en riesgo te da miedo y
buscas una alternativa a esto y entonces
buscamos en el facebook perdón en las
redes sociales y buscamos quien me pueda
decir qué hacer con mi dolor de espalda
te van a decir que vayas con el western
o con el quiropráctico con todo respeto
para ellos o te van a decir tal doctor o
tal la atención es la buena pero quien
los convierte a ellos en expertos
quien los convierte a ellos en tener la
capacidad de decirles qué hacer con su
salud cuando uno como como profesional
muchas veces no lo puede hacer hay que
tener mucho cuidado donde buscamos esta
información y en dónde vamos a ir a
buscar la salud hace una semana estuve
un paciente que llega y lo primero que
me dice doctor sé que me tengo que
operar
ya fui a todos lados tengo más de 15
años buscando la salida y recientemente
fui a una ciudad del centro de la
república a buscar ayuda en ese lugar el
médico abrió mi cerebro con sus manos
oxígeno al cerebro lo volvió a meter
cerró sin herida alguna
y me dijo que ella estaba sanado
para empezar el problema era la columna
no sé por qué lesión en el cerebro y
para seguir él sabía cuándo salió y me
dice yo sabía que no me iba a servir de
nada y además pagué por eso para que con
gusto aunque sabía que no me iba a
servir de nada y muchas personas
buscamos estas puertas falsas porque nos
prometen milagro
hay que tener mucho cuidado y por eso
nosotros hemos detectado que hay
barreras que hacen que las personas
busquen en el lugar incorrecto pero
estas barreras tenemos que irlas
quitando poco a poco hablemos de ellas
una barrera importante es la
comunicación
podemos pensar en una barrera de
comunicación porque hable en un lenguaje
diferente un idioma diferente pero
también los mismos médicos hablamos
diferente
en mi experiencia en chiapas mi primer
paciente no estaba mi traductor me
siento después de 45 días sin ver a
nadie absolutamente y la chica de
veintitantos me decía a señas y en
lengua tzotzil que tenía un problema que
le entraba por la frente se le iba al
cuello
de ahí al corazón porque el corazón lo
tienen en el estómago y de alguna manera
salía por la boca y por los ojos en
forma de fuego
si yo también hice la misma cara no
sabía de que me estaban hablando yo al
recién egresado no hablaba sutil y lo
primero que dije además de tratar de
ayudarle es que no volví a hacer una
consulta sino un traductor
después con mi traductor al lado le dije
pregunta qué le pasa volteaba dos o tres
minutos y me decía le duele la cabeza
pregunta desde cuando volteaba dos o
tres minutos pues ya tiene ok cuánto
tiempo tiene
dos o tres minutos pues ya tiene su
tiempo citó
eso a mí me llena de angustia como poder
comunicarme con las personas y en ese
momento decidí aprender lengua y a
partir de ahí era yo quien interrogaba q
si sabe qué cosa te pasa la respuesta a
kutxa hall a kutxa putt acusación a
kutxa montón me duele el corazón la
espalda a la cabeza ok hee gim cac al
cuántos días tiene
para no hacerla muy larga volteaba ni me
decían ya tiene ya tiene su tiempo cita
el problema de comunicación no solamente
es hablar el mismo idioma la forma en
que nosotros aunque sepamos la lengua de
comunicarnos no es igual como ellos los
dos o tres minutos serán de salud
acciones de un cierto protocolo que
tienen entre ellos para comunicarse lo
mismo nos pasa hoy en el consultorio la
persona que está enfrente no habla
nuestro idioma y si nosotros no bajamos
el idioma y hablamos el castellano no
técnico y tratamos de explicarles a los
pacientes no vamos a romper esta barrera
de comunicación
las barreras económicas uno de los
grandes temores y miedos que tienen los
pacientes es cuánto me va a costar la
consulta
y si me tienen que operar cuánto me va a
costar la cirugía y si me van a operar
en cuánto tiempo me voy a recuperar y
voy a regresar a trabajar y a ser
productivo
la primera imagen es domingo y domingo
también fue mi paciente en san cristóbal
después de tres o cuatro semanas de
beber todos los días de alcohol llegó
con un síndrome de abstinencia sudoroso
temblando a punto de la crisis
convulsiva a como pude lo pasamos a la
enfermería lo hidratamos le dimos
analgésicos hicimos que se sintiera
mejor después de una mañana de estar con
nosotros es que tome esta foto en ese
momento le estaba diciendo todo lo que
habíamos hecho por él y lo que
normalmente costaría en un consultorio
su atención
él estaba temeroso angustiado ya no por
su salud sino por cómo iba a pagar eso
que había pasado
hicimos un trato
regresaría a mi consultorio tres veces a
la semana un par de horas e iba a ser
labores de ayuda de limpieza de
asistencia
por 10 veces
la segunda foto es a la décima vez ya no
hay angustia ya no hay temor se había
mantenido sobrio durante todas esas
semanas pero la barrera y sigue y sigue
en cada uno de nosotros todos tenemos
temor de cuánto nos va a costar la salud
pero si además nos vamos a una
institución pública cuánto tiempo vamos
a desperdiciar a perder ahí para tener
esa atención
las barreras geográficas esta familia de
indígenas lacandones caminaron más de 4
horas para tomar el transporte y después
7 horas de coche colectivo para llegar a
consultarme obvio hay barreras
geográficas en lugares alejados pero hay
barreras geográficas aquí mismo tenemos
problemas de movilidad tenemos problemas
para subir la silla de ruedas a la
banqueta los mismos consultorios a veces
no están preparados para recibir a los
pacientes tenemos que acabar con las
barreras geográficas y tenemos que hacer
que los pacientes puedan recibir la
atención
la más importante de todas y en la que
centro mi charla son las barreras
educativas
obviamente hay deficiencias en la
educación
pero todos en la actualidad tenemos más
acceso que hace unos años muchos de aquí
si no es que casi todos van a tener un
teléfono celular en sus manos y tienen
acceso a la información el problema es
dónde buscarla si yo pongo en un faro en
un foro o en una red social la que
quieran me duele la espalda qué puedo
hacer
estamos yendo con las personas menos
capacitadas para responder que saben
nuestros amigos a menos que tengamos un
grupo de amigos médicos que sabe la
gente en medicina hay varias formas de
saber qué tan fiable es una información
y damos cinco grados el primero es el
más alto y el quinto es el más bajo el
quinto es la experiencia de un experto
pero por más experto que sea es la más
baja imagínense que sabe la vecina la
tía la amiga o la hermana sobre tu dolor
entonces ahí hay que cambiar hay que
buscar la información en ciertas zonas
donde la información sea correcta en
páginas de instituciones educativas o de
salud pero también como médicos tenemos
que educarnos tenemos que educarnos
porque a nadie nos enseñan a ser
empáticos a ser cálidos a dar
información en el consultorio a nadie
nos enseñan ni siquiera cómo cobrar eso
se va dando con la práctica se va dando
con la experiencia y con algunos tumbos
que te da la vida pero nosotros también
tenemos que aprender a educar a nuestros
pacientes a darles información ya
convertir el consultorio incluso en un
salón de clases
el miedo a la cirugía de columna es a lo
que me enfrento todos los días justo
ayer una chica que ya había acudido con
otro médico
dice lo primero que quiero decirle
doctor es que no me quiero operar
yo le dije lo primero que quiero decirte
es buenos días cómo estás soy miguel
santana en que te puedo ayudar déjame
conocerte déjame saber que te duele y
entonces charlamos
en el camino de entrada yo ya sabía que
tenía debilidad porque llego con un
andador y arrastrando un pie pero antes
de conocerte te puedo decir que ya
tienes un problema neurológico
vamos a ver qué te pasa ya me dice tiene
debilidad tiene alteración de la fuerza
alteración de los reflejos y un dolor
que no se mejora con nada
déjame ver tus estudios una gran hernia
de disco
de más del 50% de invasión
necesitas una cirugía doctor no quiero
operarme tengo miedo
qué te han dicho sobre esto nada el
médico que viste nada me dijo que me
tenía que operar y cuánto costaba ahí es
donde nosotros tenemos que cambiar y
tenemos que enfocarnos en poder dar
alternativas si yo le digo a ella puede
que quedes bien puede que quede es mal
no se va a operar si yo le digo a ella
cuidado porque se complican no se va a
operar
pero si yo a ella le digo que el índice
de complicaciones es del 3 al 5 por
ciento de la manera mejor que se pueda
si le digo que el índice de éxito de esa
cirugía es de aproximadamente del 85 al
90 por ciento y es más fácil para que
entendamos toda la complicación está
aquí y el éxito está acá pero si no te
haces nada es al revés que prefieres y
ahí empezó a cambiar hoy antes de esta
conferencia me escribió muy temprano y
me dice doctor me quiero operar ya
decidí pero tengo miedo a que me duela
más porque me dicen que me va a doler
más entonces hay que tener la paciencia
de explicarle nuevamente todo esto que
estamos hablando
el miedo como dominarlo educándonos
empezando a creer que hay nuevos
pacientes todos ustedes van a llegar hoy
informados al consultorio van a llegar
con más ganas de intercambiar
información ustedes ya cambiaron ya
tienen esa información pero los médicos
nos quedamos ahí estos médicos que
muchas veces no aprendimos de otra
manera hoy tenemos que hacerlo educando
tenemos que ayudar a que nuestros
pacientes dialogan con nosotros debatan
que no nos sentamos agredidos porque nos
preguntan no nos cuestionen tenemos que
cambiar en ese aspecto y estar de
acuerdo en que la mejor manera de llevar
a un paciente a salud a la salud de ser
empático ser cálidos dar mucha
información despejar todas las dudas
y por último quiero decirles a los
padres ya no le echen miedo con los
médicos ni con las enfermeras a veces ni
siquiera inyectamos yo soy miguel
santana soy médico y estoy para
servirles